this season has been experienced a
whirlwind because in your own words has
has this experience been for you
great it's been it was I don't know for
me it was like so much fun loved it
so how's Alexa how's married life it's
going well it's it's honestly it's the
best
um
everyone we hear all the time people are
like oh marriage is the hardest thing
ever for us it's the easiest thing ever
it's so much fun it's very easy going
home and talking to her every day maybe
roommate issues are difficult sometimes
but it's it's great
so Matt has married like for you yeah
it's the same thing we're doing awesome
it's uh you learn a lot about each other
after getting done with this whole this
whole season or the whole series and all
this stuff um
but just kind of morphing each other's
lives and incorporating each other in
each other's lives and just growing it's
been uh it's been fun it's been really
good actually do you guys find it hard
to incorporate you guys like your lives
together or has it been super easy like
to turn this you know I will say at
first it was It was kind of tough
because you do all of us went into this
single right so we do have a kind of set
schedule
um so at first it was kind of like all
right well I do this all the time she
doesn't necessarily like me doing this
okay well now I can't do this anymore so
it's it was tough at first but we
learned and um and right now it's as
good as it's been amazing yeah SK
I was very surprised you said no
actually I was shocked I I gasped so why
what happened what's your relationship
status now
um I think with Raven and I you know
like we we our relationship wasn't
straightforward from the beginning right
we come from two different worlds two
different backgrounds and we really
really tried uh to make that work from
from day one uh when I proposed to her I
felt like I had enough for me to want to
move forward and you know hopefully
resolve those differences uh by the time
we got to the altar I don't think those
differences were resolved and I didn't
think adding a marriage on top of that
would help
changed or resolved those differences we
had very different ideas of you know
fundamental things about family about
you know location where to live and
things like that and getting married was
not like the ultimate Halo that was
going to fix that for me it was very
very difficult like watching her on the
stage and you know just break down in
tears watching my mom my family everyone
around it was very very hard for me to
do right now Raven and I are just like
taking things one at a time I did reach
out you know we did talk after the
wedding and you know make sure she was
good you know we still care about each
other but we're just taking things one
day at a time
I got that so Cole you had a very
different wedding situation
um I think what you were being told at
the altar must have been very tough how
was that how did you feel about that did
you wish she did in a different way how
how did you process that all yeah of
course I wish it would have gone a
different way it was a horrible day it
was on the worst days of my life but she
you know spoke her mind and said what
was true to her and so
um yeah I mean I can't I can't change it
uh but uh yeah it was a very rough day
do you guys still have any type of
relationship and Communications yeah
yeah I mean we'll be you'll be seeing us
we're you know talking and we're still
cordial it's just
working some things out
and so parties use as well did not get
married how are you and Nancy now do you
guys have a relationship anything what's
going on well from since wedding day
since the altar
um I think I I made it clear that I was
willing to pursue something with Nancy
after and she was just like no this is
cutting drives the black and white we're
done like out of here
um and it's kind of ironic like what
love is blind displays of our
relationship is very much a roller
coaster and that's kind of continued
with our friendship so we've gone from
from no communication to like okay let's
try and be friends to back to no
communication to now we're this all this
is all blowing up again so let's be
acquaintances so it's still been all
over the place but we do communicate we
do talk
um my relationship status now is single
um and me and me and Nancy are not
planning on anything romantic in our
future yeah yeah so that's actually
brought up a good point that I want to
ask do you guys feel like your
relationship was portrayed fairly on the
television show
we didn't have a single fight there was
whatever that came on so it was very
interesting to see how it was going to
play we were kind of we were nervous
honestly the whole time we were like
this is gonna look fake we've never had
an issue or an argument or anything but
it very that was very much the case from
day one until wedding day
cool cool and then you guys this season
you guys really stayed away from talking
about physical traits like you guys did
not talk about all on the pods and
that's very different from the past two
seasons I feel like a lot more people
did try talking about it do you guys
regret that decision or are you guys
Happy how that went what's your thoughts
for me I was very intentional about not
talking about you know anything physical
up until right after we got our phones
after the pause I had no idea what
Pilates was I had to Google it and you
know it was it was by Design right I
didn't want to know because to me it
wasn't like primary it was secondary you
know like if she came out like when she
walked out and I was like
the smoke show that she is
uh you know to me that was like icing on
the cake right so um I just I was very
intentional about that
so do you know are we doing Pilates now
I mean she made me do it several times
look at this body that's it I didn't
know what Alexa did until what was it
like day three of Malibu I was talking
to the guys and they're like it's kind
of weird you don't even know what she
does and it's like it is kind of weird
yeah I remember that and I also as a
viewer I really found that jealousy and
insecurities really well I think toward
your couples like couples apart do you
guys agree with that do you think do you
think that was a fair assessment
how I found like jealousy and
insecurities are really one of the
driving forces of like relationships not
happening so I was curious if you guys
agree with that I think it comes back to
communication yeah I don't think there
was jealousy in involved as much as
maybe as displayed the problem with my
relationship specifically had nothing to
do with jealousy
and do you guys believe love is truly
blind yes it can be yes absolutely
why do you think there's a difference I
think Love is Blind but marriage is not
always blind that's perfect I love can
be blind yeah I love candy love you can
fall in love blindly and that's and
that's a good point yeah love is blind
because I obviously fell in love in the
pods and went through with it but you
learned so much more after you get out
of it so yes love is blind but yeah
there's still a lot to learn after
getting out of it and do you guys miss
the Pods at all oh I love the paws oh I
love installing everything was great in
the pot
that was the best time of my life just
after that no
don't recommend it
we're gonna recreate the project in your
house like we try doing it again uh you
know what it could it can be used in
relationships I think it's a very
healthy thing actually like if you're
already with someone and y'all are
having some type of a difficulty just
put a wall between y'all and talk and it
would it probably would really help it's
crazy because on campus at Berkeley we
have like this small little soundproof
interview pods for like grad students
when you have like employer interviews
and right after the show came out my
career services office made like a meme
about it like when you're walking to the
spots to get a job like this is like a
relationship make sure you bring your
home absolute best foot forward so when
I look at those phone pods on campus now
I have trauma
well we don't love trauma but thank you
guys so much for your time thank you
very much